oh this story is sure not to be
problematic the movie begins on a small
island off the West Coast where a
photographer named Samuel roams around
taking pictures we noticed that most
people he takes pictures of are sleeping
in random places as it turns out a
strange crisis has hit the island three
days ago people started falling asleep
out of nowhere in the middle of a car
ride inside a sauna and even while
swimming underwater that guy's dead at
first The Observers were simply confused
but they soon found out that the ones
who slept would not wake up almost as if
they were in a coma several doctors and
researchers have come to the island in
the past 72 hours but no one has found a
cure to the unique pandemic by now all
the permanent residents of the island
are asleep the lucky ones in their homes
some at work while others are in the
grocery store or in their cars their
bodies are functioning properly except
anytime they are moved from the original
place they fell asleep their pulse goes
abnormally High an interesting thing
about this situation is that the
phenomenon doesn't affect those who were
not a permanent resident of the island
prior to the occurrence hence scientists
have established a camp and put tags on
every sleeping human on the island to
keep track of them currently no reporter
is allowed in the infected Zone but
Samuel has somehow managed to sneak
through the Border amidst the chaos
while on the adventure he enters a Bus
full of sleeping passengers to take
pictures he discovers a woman holding a
live goldfish and decides to take it
with him in the bizarre circumstance
Samuel feels like the fish is his only
friend and he talks to the animal
accordingly sometime later they end up
at a house which looks good enough to
spend a few days in Samuel cautiously
walks in to find a woman sleeping on her
bed her name is Stella and she was one
of the lucky last ones to fall asleep
Samuel avoids invading her privacy and
stays in the other room not realizing
that the researchers are outside his
house guarding the area since everyone
conscious has been asked to leave the
island he is afraid he will be punished
if found the following day Samuel dreams
of going to the grocery store and run
turning into Stella but she hardly pays
any attention to him oh not even in his
dreams he has woken up abruptly when he
calls her by her name and she asks him
how he knows it a new day Sparks a new
adventure for Samuel as he talks to a
sleeping Stella while listening to the
news on the radio the entire world is
talking about the pandemic and the
bizarre controversies are starting to
roll in laughing at them Samuel decides
to explore the island in the daylight
the first person he notices is a
handyman stuck to a tree sleeping
peacefully he also finds out the animals
on the island are still alive and
wonders who is taking care of them after
about an hour of walking he reaches the
church where a large group of people are
unconscious taking a few pictures Samuel
settles into a seat and falls asleep in
his dream he and Stella are sitting
opposite each other in a restaurant they
act like they have known each other
forever and chat about what Samuel is
doing on the island Stella doesn't
approve that he is taking advantage of
the situation for money but Samuel
argues that he is there for the
experience not the money later the money
may be but not now later on he returns
home and goes through Stella's
belongings to find her Daily Journal as
he reads it his connection to Stella
gets stronger and he continues dreaming
about her in the dream she tells him
that she was one of the last ones to get
hit the first person she saw falling
unconscious was her piano teacher who
slept in the middle of a class on being
asked if she was scared Stella replies
that she was more confused the doctors
and researchers came but only discovered
that the people should not be moved from
the places they fell asleep Stella finds
it funny that there is a chance her
heart will explode if she gets up from
her bed Samuel says if she does that his
dick might explode too Samuel then takes
the opportunity to ask her how she felt
when she fell asleep Stella describes it
as a surreal feeling she had strange
vivid dreams and eventually got lost in
them not realizing that she was falling
into a deep sleep the scene then changes
to the next day and Samuel sets out on
yet another adventure he goes to a
different neighborhood this time around
and ends up seeing a car filled with
balloons while trying to take a picture
of it he noticed is the health workers
nearby and has to run back home the
incident brings Samuel back to reality
and he decides to leave the island
having taken enough pictures he wishes
goodbye to Stella packs his belongings
and goes to the shore where his boat is
however after spending quite some time
at the shore looking at the boat he
decides otherwise just when he reaches
home he sees the faucet is running
Samuel remembers that it was running the
first time he entered the house but he
is positive that he had turned it off
suddenly He is transferred back to his
dream sitting opposite Stella at the
restaurant she inquires about the actual
reason he came to the island Samuel
finally comes clean that he came here to
look at boobies just kidding he came
here for her as it turns out one year
ago he was on the island on vacation
when he saw Stella at the grocery store
he followed her to a restaurant later
that day where she seemed young and free
which piqued his interest but before he
could ask for her number the night ended
and he never got to meet her again back
in reality Samuel goes to the grocery
store to shop but two researchers come
in to get some alcohol at the same time
one of them bumps into Samuel but he
avoids getting caught by pretending to
be unconscious after they are gone he
delightedly shops for Essentials and
even pays the sleeping cashier before
bringing the groceries home after that
we see him roam around Stella's house
observing her belongings and imagining
what her personality would be like he
hits the jackpot when he finds a tape
recorder in the Attic that has
recordings of the list of her favorite
things the list has random things like
the sound of a typewriter headless
Barbie dolls and Flamingo floaties but
the more Samuel listens to it the more
his infatuation grows even though
judging by that tape she's a complete
psychopath on the list Stella describes
that driving on the beach is her
favorite thing to do and so Samuel
imagines him and Stella outside looking
for a car to drive to the beach he
dreads the idea of stealing from
sleeping people but Stella convinces him
that they're just borrowing it they soon
find a car they like and break into the
owner's house to look for the keys
Samuel enjoys Stella's free-spirited
nature and the fact that she's a
criminal starts believing that she is
more than just his imagination a while
later he wakes up to the sound of a car
outside and notices two health workers
coming into the house for a weekly
checkup he hurriedly takes all of his
belongings and hides in a closet seconds
before being caught the workers checked
Stella for any abnormalities and leave
not long after Samuel spends the rest of
his day laying beside Stella's bed and
talking to her Stella I think I've gone
insane what's that I haven't well that's
a relief the next day he yet again goes
to the attic and plays the second part
of her tape this time she talks about
the things she hates and reveals that
she feels lonely and vulnerable Samuel
wishes he could do something to make her
feel better which in turn makes him feel
helpless yet again he drifts into his
imagination and starts chatting with her
the duo talks about soul mates and how
everyone has one Samuel suggests they
might be each other's soulmate but
Stella doesn't believe it coming back to
reality Samuel finally decides to go
back home now that he has no purpose to
be on the island he makes it halfway to
the dock but cannot get himself to leave
Stella at night he returns home and gets
high off Stella's stash dreaming about
them smoking together starting that day
he makes it his mission to do all the
things that were on Stella's list of
things she loved he makes lasagna and
drinks beer out of a wine glass for the
same reason when Tipsy Stella appears in
his dreams Furious about him not leaving
her alone she declares that the version
of Stella he knows from her journals and
tapes is not her Samuel recognizes that
she is right after all he has never
talked to her in real life and their
relationship is entirely in his head as
he tries convincing himself coming to
the island was not a mistake Stella asks
him to leave her alone and disappears
into the darkness in the following scene
Samuel once again decides to leave but
his journey is different this time
around he feels extremely thirsty on his
way and gets strange hallucinations to
quench his thirst he breaks into an
apartment but the more he drinks the
thirstier he gets the walls start
closing on him filling him up with
anxiety which is when he realizes is
about to fall asleep like the others as
he tries his best to stay awake he gets
a call from imaginary Stella who calls
him back home he suddenly wakes up and
returns to her house in a hurry
asserting that if falling asleep is
inevitable he would rather sleep close
to her the next morning to Samuel's
utter surprise he wakes up however he is
unsure how long he can stay awake for
taking the opportunity at hand he writes
notes for Stella in case she ever gets
to read them it takes him the entire day
and at the end he too falls into a coma
time passes and a few days later Stella
moves in her sleep things take a turn
when she opens her eyes wide awake after
being asleep for more than a week she
realizes that she has no energy and goes
to drink water from the faucet this is
when she sees a second toothbrush on the
counter and figures someone else has
been living with her while cautiously
approaching a sleeping Samuel in the
living room Stella is more confused than
scared she wants to wake him up but
gives up after a few tries the house is
filled with random objects she likes
like a Barbie without her head and a
giant Flamingo floaty Stella is
pleasantly surprised to see them but it
washes away as soon as she finds out
Samuel read her journals and listened to
her Taves in a fit of rage she hits him
several times and discovers the notes he
wrote for her in them he apologizes to
her for listening to her tapes and
assures her that she is like everyone
else he tells her feeling lonely and
building up a defense system is okay but
asks her to be herself the notes
overwhelm Stella as she figures out that
the stranger in her house knows her
inside out and she too feels like she
has known him forever in the next few
days she gets several dreams with Samuel
in them they chat about his likes
dislikes fears and responsibilities as
he did with her in his dreams even
though they have not even met each other
in real life Stella knows they are
connected hence she takes care of him
like he did to her then comes the
morning when Stella wakes up later than
usual to a pleasant surprise Samuel is
no longer on the sofa he was sleeping on
the two meet each other in the kitchen
for the first time but to them it feels
like they are lovers reuniting after
decades Samuel introduces himself and
shakes hands with her delighted to know
that she is just as happy to meet him in
the final scene we are brought back to
the bus where it all started the woman
whose goldfish Samuel had stolen wakes
up from her sleep and we see that she
now has two fishies in her hands instead
of one this movie brought to you by
chloroform
except for a few people back in London
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching